this is just a quick video with
commentary to give you an idea of how
these levels work and how approaching
you can see points levels have diamonds
in the bubble fireflies levels have
fireflies in the bubble and toys levels
have a rubber duck so we're just going
to go to the first one I'm just going to
skip through the centro real quick so
this will give us the tutorial that
comes along with the game will expand on
that some more alright so you can see
it's shown us that the greenish blue
blocks have toys underneath them and to
collect them we have to make matches
over top so since this is the first one
it's the easiest toys level a couple
couple things to look at is the number
of total toys you need is right here
this is just general gameplay but you
could click on this right now but
instead what I'm going to do since I'm
going to get the water out of here as
fast as possible so let the water in
first because when you work from the top
down you get you don't mess up the
matches that are below it I just
collected nine so you see my title goes
up to nine out of 33 and like I said now
I can just exit the room and one click
this is you know this is as simple as it
comes toys it can also be later they'll
be in tanks where you'll have to hit the
tank a few times and you'll get a
certain number of them to escape and
there are also be times when there are
not any extra toys on the level at all
so you can't leave them behind like I
did right there so we'll look at one of
those in a minute we got 16 out of 33
though we're in the last room and as you
can see there's plenty of toys around
for us to collect we also have a colored
these charged up so you can look real
quick it looks like green is pretty good
since there's only two colors both of
them are good then to help us finish the
level but in their simplest form that is
what a toys level is so I'm gonna go
through and play a couple more of them
and look through some different
situations that I can point out I don't
have any particular ones in mind so
we'll just play a couple and see what we
find all right okay I had to pause for a
second there because the game server
went down but now we can pick up with
the toys level
alright so this one we have to collect
50 toys and we see they have the regular
ones that we saw before the ground
blocks that are sort of a greenish blue
those have toys underneath them and then
we also have the porous raised ground
box and we'll have to make matches next
to those to get to the toy so since
we're looking for a large number we're
going to start from the top will free up
all those bring the water down step by
step and that's all there is to getting
those toys just make a match next to
them and they're just like these blocks
here the blocks disappear all the ones
that are being touched
same exact thing here these are the
cracked ground box with the snow on top
and welcome match to make one match and
it makes it a regular ground ball and
make another match then you get your toy
call it dance dancing to the page last
you up so again like I said a cold right
now soon gonna make some strange noises
that's what's problem
alright so these ones of those like
they'll be difficult to get and we don't
have the little ! tell us we need to get
these ones so generally speaking if we
don't need those toys and it's going to
waste a lot of moves to try to get them
making the skipping
all right now with this is I want to
show this anyways this is the day ! and
as you can see it's going off telling us
that there's no extra ones in here we
have to get every single one before we
leave the room so we're going to want to
stay away from getting that get in the
water all the way to the exit so that we
can collect all of them before we move
on
and so as long as we don't make this red
match down here we'll be okay and you
see what can happen if you run out of
matches to make at the top before that !
goes away which it just did then and not
in this room so much but in some rooms
you are there for you the only match you
can make is the one that's going to open
the door so we got 37 now and you can
see that the alert went away so we can
go ahead and move on because we'll have
a hard time getting to those rooms up
there alright this is last room we need
to get 12 when we have 18 sitting there
a 50 no's so this shouldn't be too bad
just need to pick up six more now
you could like do you can do this to get
some extra points to raise your score if
you want to get a couple extra ones but
that is that's how that works I just
want to find one really quickly let me
just do the same one again so I can
point out how those exclamation points
do you work and because this is a
question that a lot of times people ask
so I'll fire this back up again I'll
show you what happens look a question
I've heard a lot is how come I have like
X amount of moves you know like 30 moves
left and get the level still over and
the reason that happens sometimes is
because you move on while that alert is
still going so I'm going to skip a bunch
of them and see if I can't make that
happen
that's it it's not doing it now so see
what happens
so I'm just getting through the exits
vessel can and then just going to
continue to keep missing room
alright so now we see the alert again
which tells us we need to collect them
all but I'm gonna ignore it and see what
happens I bet it's still there and
unless season these last two that I'm
going to pick up my open the door get us
to where we needed to go okay it didn't
so here it is it says you missed too
many toys so any time you're playing a
toys level or a fire fires level for
that matter and you see that alert but
you don't pick up enough of them that's
going to tell you get missed too many
toys and there we had several moves left
but they're they're gone right away
because the water got to the exit and
then move on to the next board and that
will stop you from being able to finish
so those are the basic ins and outs of
toys levels like I mentioned earlier in
the video there's um they're in tanks
sometimes which makes it a little bit
harder but it still works the same way
with the tanks you crack the tank until
it opens up and then they go to the
ground box afterwards so you won't see
that for a while but if you have any
questions about this or anything else
you can leave a comment you can join our
group and ask there that's the fastest
way to get in touch with us or you can
go to our website and leave a comment on
this page Diamond digger saga tips com
alright hope this helps you understand
let us know if you need anything else
and please like the video if you found
it helpful